thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another highly
satisfactory episode of the careful boys
what's up [ __ ] hello
what's up with that that's not good it's
gonna be it's gonna be a very good one
okay I believe you
um today
we're each gonna take turns
looking directly at the camera not at
each other okay and say happy Hanukkah
and say something honest to the fans oh
all right let me see I'm nothing but
honesty so I gotta shoot you can't go
first because yours has to be really big
okay fine but I don't know what else I
can expose I [ __ ] talk so much
already
really addressed something directly at
the fans so what should we say to the
fans I'll go first I'll go first and set
the tone and I'll go first okay
hello JK audience
um here's my honest opinion of
everything uh first of all I love
working on this show I love doing social
media I love answering other guys's
questions in the DMS
um I really it honestly does affect me
in a very positive way to hear stories
of how long some of you guys have been
watching and how you attribute coming
out of depressions or uh getting through
school with JK and stuff like that I
wasn't on JK at the time but I enjoy
hearing those things and relaying them
to everybody else and uh I I thought
that when I used to come here as a guest
I remembered
someone had told me after I left here
they were like oh dude don't read the
comments and I was like why and they're
like dude the JK audience sucks they're
talking that was my first time here and
I was like really and I went to the
comments after my first episode here as
a guest and like everyone hated me they
were all talking total [ __ ] they were
right every person in the comments was
making fun of me in a different way that
I'd never heard I've never been insulted
in any one of those ways before in my
life it was my Indian body counts what
the [ __ ] and then I just remember
thinking damn okay it's like that cool
whatever and then um you know as time
went on and I started coming on here
more I mean it did happen less but then
now because I have that to compare it to
I I can say with confidence that the JK
audience of this exact era is completely
ideal and you know that was that was a
orchestrated event by me
wow that's you're really good at the
camera
the camera you're very good at that so
uh and he never takes credit for things
he hasn't done that's true okay
but yeah I just wanted to say to the JK
fans of now uh thanks for being so
[ __ ] cool like everybody's just
really really hey you're welcome you're
welcome it's still you well there's
nobody nobody watches the show we have
to juice the console a little bit so
it's like me Joe Barr we we take turns
video
thank you for the participation and
everything and for engaging with with us
as much as we try to engage back with
you guys and I hope
um I hope you all feel heard and seen
and everything yeah I want to do [ __ ]
Thunder do it because you just triggered
a memory well it's not even a [ __ ]
triggered memory but like you want you
want not all jokes aside though okay
um as a content creator I [ __ ] up a
couple years ago by creating a space
that I felt that maybe everybody needs
to be heard in my team where I I [ __ ]
up Doug we had too many [ __ ] wokies
straight up this is a comedy show and
you're paying too much money come here
and joke the [ __ ] around dude you know
what I mean during the covet era all
that [ __ ] and then we got scared we got
all of us got [ __ ] scared to be like
our true self this is the truth because
like before I felt like everybody loved
us for just being naturally who we were
and then things came in like oh we can't
say this oh we gotta be [ __ ] secret
about this thing that's happening
personally we never [ __ ] had to do
that [ __ ] right and I was like okay
what's going on because
um one we had too many
um
people that we just needed to fill seats
with because during Cove it was hard
nobody wanted to come on the show
they're [ __ ] everyone was coughing
all day they're getting sick and [ __ ]
and they or or they're just scared you
literally filled my seat with a dummy
one time and it was the most nice
concert I ever got that was me that was
but it was hard bar was producing and it
was so [ __ ] hard to fill the seats in
especially like yeah during that time
you know everyone was afraid to [ __ ]
leave their front door and [ __ ] right
and on top of that the Judgment that
people got how dare you [ __ ] film in
the middle of all this [ __ ] and it's
like dude we're we're an essential
business we're our news channel we need
to [ __ ] get the breaking news out
hard news right so that was a really
pivotal moment where I was like I don't
like the content I'm creating I don't
like the [ __ ] audience I've
cultivated because they're all fighting
in the cons because half of us like the
comedy that we created the other half
are the [ __ ] wokies that got
cultivated because I wanted everybody to
be heard and [ __ ] and then
I was like you know what
the reason why we build companies is to
be a dictatorship yeah I want my I want
my vision to be seen I'm I'm doing this
in the funniest tyrannical way possible
but in and and and and
um and all and what I want to say is
basically
the execution
went out very beautifully because now
we're in an era where I I think this is
so much more truer to what I wanted this
channel to be would you call this damn
sure it was the most beautiful attitude
and I think you guys yeah along with the
audience because now we're in this place
where I feel like hey we can breathe
again and do comedy again and we can
talk about you know whatever we want to
and just enjoy each other's company
without getting too [ __ ] serious
without having like I don't know like
it's not it's it's there's no judgment
in this group so one amazing things
about us individually
start with Anthony you're gonna be last
bro just like Joe was going to be last
for this exercise and yeah you still
took the monologue it was a beautiful
model it's it's going right you
sorry dude yeah it's probably gonna suck
I'm not gonna say anything for this
video I want to hear everybody because
in my tyrannical show that I run here
that I've done everything for you're not
saying anything important right now
what's the point of you talking about
everybody's voice edited this out can
you cut this out Ken your voice matters
can by the way
wrap it up right
that's literally the evolution that I
wanted for this Channel and you and I
couldn't have done it without this team
and the audience behind it so I'm super
thankful for for this group and also you
guys watching too and for all of you
that actually came down to jumbee and
Hawaii like making us one of your guys
and a lot of you have been coming up and
the funny thing is a lot of women have
been coming up saying this is the
funniest [ __ ] era of JK news
table
because of your guys's support and being
all believe all women's team yeah yeah
all right well so honestly
because I I know what you meant I know
you meant even when you were joking but
no uh yeah this group this particular
group is my favorite group that I've
worked with in the show yeah and then
you know you know I've worked with a lot
of people it's just about this the first
there's a lot of group mind in here
which is you know one of the best things
about you know having a a team that you
know you can I can look into your eyes
and I know where you're trying to go and
I want to help you get there right and
like that's the best thing about this
team is I can I can suss you guys out
and I think you guys can suss me out
because I can feel you guys have my back
if I gesture something I can I can hear
you guys quiet down or vice versa I can
we just have a good way of knowing what
each other wants to say and also too
like
um you know even what just happened with
Bart like the way that people just came
out of nowhere to
you know reassess or like re-state their
support
it's it's just awesome like I just you
can see the love out there which
sometimes we all you know get into our
own [ __ ] but then seeing all that
love come out like I just and and by the
way the way that Bart handled that [ __ ]
dude you are like the strongest
[ __ ] like like period and how we
couldn't wait to roast him about it when
he came back well the real bro [ __ ] the
real bro well of course but the real
brothers were thinking that but yes the
real bro [ __ ] is that he sat here for
like multiple JK like episodes for days
and like didn't want to like the truth
is that he didn't want to impact the
boys like he didn't want to [ __ ] with
the content which is just the most Bart
thing ever even though everyone wants to
console board or whatever the fact that
he did that is like one of the strongest
things I've ever seen and that strength
is not burying things but he's just
trying to make it conducive to like
getting the the job done right so I yeah
to me I mean like this place was
intended to be like a magical place and
in the beginning like kind of like
alluding to what Joe was saying it was
really cool because it was a place where
people from all different walks of life
came together like uh different states
different upbrings whatever and I think
that's what people really really vibed
with because when we met people like in
the beginning we're all about Asian
American empowerment we're doing like
all the the sketch comedy stuff and then
we're like oh [ __ ] like our demographic
and following is like anyone and
everyone
so
um but we we're just uh United by this
like-mindedness and this like-mindedness
of we all see things differently but we
also embraced each other about it and
over the years uh people's different
positions became something to defend
which was not the intention of what we
started we started to we wanted it to be
different positions because it'll be
boring if we all agreed on the same [ __ ]
but we we want it to be let's be
different positions but embrace it but
it became a point of defense and it
became a point of Defense not only here
but also reflected in the audience
and so like once we got it back to a
place where like the magic was
we could say crazy [ __ ] I could say
something that potentially is Gonna
Cancel me but five other people will get
my back immediately or they'll edit it
out
well they'll pull you aside that we
should just edit this out just have your
back one or the other yeah like
and I know how sacred that is you know
so like when we come here and we're all
old now we all got our own [ __ ] when we
come here it's such a magical place and
a magical time and like an experience
that like when crazy [ __ ] was happening
to me I I didn't want to affect it even
though it was big so I wanted to
maintain the Purity that we have been
able to bring it back to and just to
talk to the audience directly
um I think it's [ __ ] cool that like
we're probably one of the longest
YouTubers since 2013 2007 all the way
until now and to have this strong
support as we as we grow up as they grow
up I don't know how many people I've met
that told me they've been watching since
they're junior high or people that
[ __ ] they look older than me and they
have [ __ ] kids now and [ __ ] and it's
just crazy that they've the people that
understood the magic stayed with the
magic through even tough times or
whatever and they just kind of kept
going until now and
I'm super grateful for all of that I had
a I had like a x-ray guy a radiologist
he's like putting the lead vest on me
thing because I was at kidney stones
he's like by the way I'm Big Jake
oh [ __ ] you don't know but then you're
like
this guy watches JK yeah yeah we're
[ __ ] he's gonna look at my dick oh
yeah like well yeah and it's well it's
also like it's like holy [ __ ] like we we
the first thought you know we're [ __ ]
idiots like this guy watches it like
what's he gonna do to me
I would prefer a non-fad to work on me
please yeah
it kind of goes together with what he
was saying in the very beginning about
the whole comets thing too and I think
over the years people get too like
invested into comments and making sure
that people aren't talking [ __ ] about
them to the point where now they wanna
like oh I better [ __ ] fight back
because people are saying I'm a [ __ ] in
the comments so then now it's not about
the group here having a good time now
it's about like I gotta protect my
[ __ ] Pride yeah and then that's what
I think I had to eliminate because it's
like if you're self-preserve preserving
you're not entertaining you're here not
worrying about how you look on camera
and how you want to look cool and like
now you got to be the one that's like
kind of pointing fingers like oh you
guys aren't doing this right because the
comments are gonna give me a horror but
then when the cameras go off you're not
[ __ ] acting like that then I'm just
like you're dunking on other things too
[ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah it's like
you're using us as a tool to do that
[ __ ] I think those are the things that I
really needed to eliminate you know and
then and then really get back to that
point and it's like it all kind of goes
back to the same to preserve this thing
that we intended so they can enjoy a
good watching viewing experience
or even a you know a mediocre one yeah
sometimes they are I'm sure you know
every now and then Anthony Lee no I'm
going last if I'm going at all Nick all
right let's do it man all right well uh
mine's gonna suck anyway so
well first like I never thought I'd be
in a room like this or you know get to
do anything like this so it's I'm very
thankful and grateful to be here a part
of something that you guys have built
and you guys have trusted me to kind of
come into the group and kept me on so
I'm very thankful of that and also to
the fans out there that everyone watches
I feel like I've been welcomed with open
arms and no one's like you know giving
me too much [ __ ] but everyone's like
been so great like my overall experience
has been so so positive people send me
really funny messages all the time
people like send jokes they try to clown
on me and it's [ __ ] makes me the best
yeah it makes me laugh people send me
hospital memes people send me that
[ __ ] UFC fighter that the Mexican
dude that looks like me I guess the
Roses higher guy yeah they say he looks
like you if he was cauliflower
no I mean it's just cool bro like I just
I I've never
thought I'd be in a position like this
where random people may come up to you
and be like hey I watch JK I'm like oh
cool I still don't know how to [ __ ]
react to that but um yeah just being a
part of a group that's being a part of
something that's bigger than you is
something that I felt like was really
cool especially coming off the pandemic
where for a while I was feeling kind of
like lost because like my work and
everything that I was doing was so like
stagnant in a certain place like and
then being able to be brought onto
something like this was been like
been a dream ever since you know and the
support from everybody has been great
um and then being like hanging out with
you guys and building relationships with
you guys has been even cooler and
expanding the network and
being able to be in a room where we
could just talk [ __ ] and say ridiculous
things all day just to make each other
laugh like that's a [ __ ] dream and
the fact that people are willing to
watch and comment and show love is
pretty [ __ ] crazy dude I don't know I
think it's a trip every single day
um so I'm just happy to be here and I'm
just very thankful for everyone that
watches you know so I appreciate
everyone commenting like everything that
you see people the same people
commenting the hardcore fans like they
they're there all the time man and it's
just really cool and it's a testament to
what you guys have built you know and I
never thought I'd be rubbing elbows with
you know a bunch of Hot Shots like you
guys not for real well no also aside
though like like you guys are all you
know masters of your craft in your own
way and then the fact that we can come
together and build something that is so
like
different than what you guys normally do
you know is like really [ __ ] cool I
appreciate that I get to sit next to a
brown belt all the time too it's [ __ ]
amazing
don't be gay
it's black but I'll settle no but all
jokes aside too like when when I'm at
the airport and somebody comes to me and
like yo Steve Green [ __ ] hinges I'm like
that's so beautiful like that's so
that's just so like that's so [ __ ]
beautiful like what do you think about
it you know in our lives when we went we
went to eat yesterday right I checked
that you posted on Instagram and the
first top comment is they're having a
great time because Anthony's not there
and it was by a girl hey you know what
dude I was missing that you were there I
wish you were there Anthony no no I get
it it's like when Joe's not here we
actually finish on time and everything
why would that happen we're gonna end it
beautifully Anthony yeah mine's gonna
suck so keep our expectations about
working that's why you said that yours
never such you're always good at
everything you want some honesty and we
don't want too much group Minds so like
everybody says something positive I have
to say you know other [ __ ] right say the
negative stuff all of us in a row you
know it's like uh 100 honest all
transparency I probably had like you
know two off-care remotes where I was
like guys I don't really want you guys
to be making fun of me roasting me all
the time because it's like I don't want
that to be part of my branding and then
you guys just double down every single
time so that's be cool no no I I don't
think so I respected you such a dude
it's so true that's not true you know um
nobody's like actually promoted any kind
just things in the last six months so
like we've been losing sales and things
haven't been working but that's fine
that's look at their jacket go buy his
jacket thank you it actually comes out
next year thank you hey let's go I mean
I don't even promote my own company
stuff here same with Barb we've been
talking about
everything you didn't promote our own
stuff here I don't think I don't think
it's good for the brands no sorry go
ahead while we promote Quest groups no
we don't need to do that uh
we don't even call him a dancer is
really really wild the fact that like I
think on the objectively what we do
um there's like a monotony to it you
know what I mean like showing up you
know every single time we're doing like
20 videos a day we're like pulling
articles it's like always kind of like
this seemingly monotonous thing but the
the actual journey and the experience is
like nothing like that you know what I
mean like from straight up when um when
you know especially at the start of the
attitude area and for myself like it's
crazy to think that I've been like like
hosting for like over a year now you
know what I mean and I remember still
like my first [ __ ] host session it's
like you go in the comments of that and
there's nothing but dissension and hate
you know there's nothing but like fire
and and yeah you got Raptors just
getting wrecked that on this host video
yeah that's so crazy was dancing fire
dude you know what I'm saying but you're
still here dude you're still here well
they were killing all of us in there
dude but to truly see um even the
Channel and like where we were at like
off camera too and like some of the um
Direction and like the the uncertainty
like the subscribership and viewership
going down a lot of people jump in the
comments being like you know like this
channel is dying blah blah there was a
lot of that let's keep it real but at
the same time all of us right here this
particular group we like really stuck
through it we like took time we outside
uh of the cameras we like went on
meetings like you know you guys were
like hosting particular outings or
different Zoom creative sessions so we
can get together and try to infuse this
space and there was something about you
know like just this uh unconditional
like you know just drive to try and like
do what we believed in regardless of
like kind of like the Analytics
and then actually being able to start
seeing like you know through like social
media posts and stuff like that fans
coming back the way that people are like
yo like I I hadn't I I didn't even
remember you guys were still alive and
suddenly I'm seeing these clips and like
you guys like got me through this and
there's like been a very very huge ride
of an arc outside of kind of like the
manani of what we actually do and I feel
like those are the things that we truly
live for you know what I'm saying so
like whether people get a chance to
experience that on and off camera like
what we experienced here at jkro or at
least my truth in it it's truly like a
very very emboldening Journey that like
teaches us so much you know I mean
introduces us to so many cool new people
and builds relationships so like I you
know pay cut Jokes Aside you know what I
mean it's like the pay cuts aren't real
though that's an honest thing real but
we joke about it because we it doesn't
[ __ ] matter it doesn't [ __ ] matter
we really we love this [ __ ] we're here
for the boys honestly we're just [ __ ]
writers that when they say it you know
like us being here for each other so
like
I mean I all the fans that don't know me
and still roast me on my kids YouTube
video you guys can still suck my dick
but other than that giving you views
though even though they're leaving
stupid if you could just shut up for one
second let me speak my truth because
it's my turn to end the video the fact
that you have haters is sick I hate you
Nick
it's sick though it's sick done dude um
but yeah just Just For Real Love The
Journey love the people here uh wouldn't
have it any other way
um it is better when Joe's gone and we
get things done quickly but like we
can't do it without him so like uh give
and take compromise cool you are my
favorite Kim Jeff let's know that thank
you so much I thought you loved my song
More you dreamed about it again my song
[Laughter]
uh last session we got we got done
before six so I don't know what the [ __ ]
you talking about he's talking about you
taking shits every [ __ ] five minutes
after giant shits
three two one action dude so June B
right blob
no it's over 321 action ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
turn the cameras off I gotta take a [ __ ]
[Music]